Listening to radio lab radio from w n y. S
so nice to see you again, Jen. Uh, why is, did you say that with some vendors?
What is that all about? It's just a, you've been away for a while. The only way,
only way I can see you is when I come visit you with your other family. Okay.
So this is Radiolab producer Matt Kielty. Yeah,
we're talking about what are we talking about?
We're talking about a supreme court case from 1989 and today man has a story
that he's been reporting for about two years that we are going to play both here
on more. Perfect. And also here on radio lab. So buckle up where,
where should we start? I think we might as well just start,
should I try to sound southern with a guy named woody canet?
So I'm a lawyer with Essex Richards, a law firm in Charlotte, North Carolina.
We'll pick it up in 1985 back in 1995 I was a very young lawyer.
I was 32 years old.
I just started mountain law firm and I was taken about anything that came
through the door.
And one day [inaudible] this guy walked in a late thirties fairly thin,
five foot nine, five foot 10 bone crutches, and he's a black man. He is.
Or was, who's passed away? Mr. Graham,
the man's name is throwing gram and what he says, well, you know, like what?
What happened to your leg? What's with the crutches
and get Thorin lays everything out for him.
So he was pulled over on West Boulevard in Charlotte,
which is a four lane road to thorn until what he,
he worked for the city of Charlotte and the Department of Transportation on road
crews doing road repairs.
It was a Monday afternoon and on that day wanted to throw on his friends.
Coworkers stopped by his place and after talking for a bit,
Mr. Graham asked to be taken to a nearby convenience store.
There was only two or three blocks from his house.
He needed some orange juice because he was a suffering the onset of a diabetic
insulin reaction. So d thorn hopped in his friend's car,
they drove over to this convenience store to and got out,
got a bottle of orange shoes, got to the checkout counter,
but there's a line there. So he puts the bottle down and hurries out,
gets back in his friend's car. Did I take off now? Uh,
this is where the problems started.
Tins that at the same time,
all that's happening there is actually an officer who was African Americans
sitting in his squad car.
And what that officer observed was a man hurrying out of the store,
jumping into a whiting car and quickly driving off.
So he starts to tail to thorn and his friend and after a couple of blocks pulled
him over just to determine what was going on there.
So he goes up to the driver's side, presumably gets to thorns.
Buddy's driver's license, goes back to his squad, car, starts radioing, um,
to get, to get a hold of the convenience
store to see if anything can happen. And it's right around that moment,
that disorder who's in the passenger seat of the car suddenly opened his door,
got out of the car,
circled the car once or twice, like sort of stumbled around it.
Then he sat down on the curb
and he started going into shock a lot. Almost like a seizure he would have.
Oh really? Yeah. And it was terrifying. This is the thorn Graham Jr.
He was a type one diabetic. What is type one diabetes?
Cause I know it's one and two. From what I understand,
the type one diabetes is when you buy to just doesn't produce enough, uh,
insulin. And what would that seizure look like?
Well [inaudible] one incident in particular,
I can remember us being in church and he got like this blank stare on his face
and you see the beads of sweat come on his forehead.
His body was seized up and he would shake and he would bite his tongue up. And,
and so I can remember my mother trying to, you know,
force a spoon into his mouth to keep him from biting his tongue up.
And the main thing was try to get some orange juice in him.
That way it would raise his uh, blood sugar and, and once you got the orange,
you're saying to me he'd sleep for a couple of hours and then he'd wake up and
he'd be exhausted but he'd be alive.
Alright. So Charlotte City Street. Okay.
This point,
four other officers arrived to thorn has actually passed out on the curb.
One of the officers rolled Mr. Graham over on the sidewalk and cuffed his hands
behind his back
at one point of one of the officers grabs the thorn by the handcuffs and picks
him up off the curb from, from behind. Oh Wow.
The thorn was sort of in and out at this point.
I guess he tries to tell the officers,
but he was a diabetic that he had a medical card in his wallet,
asked the officer to pull the wallet out of his back pocket and one of the
officers said a, nothing wrong with the motherfucker buddy's drunk.
At some point around here, the details are a little unclear.
Pretty Nasty. Scuffle ensued
according to what is known as case syllabus.
Thorn was resisting the officers and apparently one of the officers slammed a
Thorne's head into his friend's car. He suffered head and shoulder injuries.
He also ended up with a broken foot, cuts around his wrist,
and eventually the officers pick him up, one on each arm,
one on each leg, and just throw him into the back of a squad car.
While this was going on, um,
a few people gathered around and not long after that,
the officers learned that nothing at all had happened at the convenience store.
There was no crime, there was no robbery, there was no shoplifting.
So they drove him back to his house, still in handcuffs,
pulled him out of the car. A friend of Thrones has gotten some OJ and, uh,
the officers light him out in his front yard,
took the handcuffs off and then just drive away. Huh?
Was there an apology? Oh No.
Now what came out
of that day in Charlotte would end up becoming one of the most important supreme
court cases in our history when it comes to policing.
And what drew me in about this case is how something,
like I needed some orange shoes,
that something so seemingly small would eventually become tied to
[inaudible] and all that.
The shootings we've seen in the past few years, mostly of young black men,
every time we hear one of these shootings, every time there is an outcry,
every time the cop gets off, this incident is looming in the shadows,
shaping the outcome. In many ways,
it is quietly defined the era that we're living in.
[inaudible]
and I wanted to know how
[inaudible], how did that happen?
The honorable,
the chief justice and the associate justices of the Supreme Court of the United
States. Oh, Yay. Yay.
Having business before the honorable, the Supreme Court of the United States.
Red Monies to draw on Aaron [inaudible],
God save the United States in this honorable card.
[inaudible]
all right. To wind back the clock a little bit are,
I will say this about my dad now. He wasn't someone that would, would, uh,
just lay down and roll over talking to the Thorn Junior.
I asked him a little bit about his dad and he told me that Thorn Sr grew up in
the south eastern North Carolina owned a tobacco farm. He was a hard worker.
Good student. His sisters told me that he was the first, uh,
black or African American accepted to Duke University. Huh. But, uh,
my grandmother, she wouldn't let him go because of, you know,
during the civil rights era that she didn't want him to have to experience, uh,
all that, all that mess.
This is a CBS news special report. And just for a little bit of context here,
I mean like the civil rights movement was a lot of things,
but there was this big part of it that was about police brutality.
Last night there was open war in 1965 you had the infamous watts riots in Los
Angeles.
My brothers make the state from battlefield
also what was known as the long hot summer of 1967.
How we got that popped right up where there were more than 150 race riots across
the country getting get data being pushed around, or you lay this out.
A lot of which were sparked by accusations of police.
Brutalities baton was on the street kicking into the doe, taking down a police,
taking a kicked in the teeth.
I will not accept charges against policemen.
I will not accept charges against policeman. This is a judge,
not some wild eyed cracker that made the statement,
although there might not be any difference. There might not be any difference.
If you can think on that,
do you understand that if we cannot bring charges against the policemen who have
murdered us and destroyed our homes and businesses, where will we go?
Where will we go?
She didn't want them to have to experience all that, all that mess.
So ended up, I think he ended up going to Fayetteville state,
a historically black college in North Carolina and winded thorn senior
graduated. Actually one of the first jobs that he had.
He worked for an employer called a precision springs.
This was a steel company that specialized in making springs,
but at a certain point he ended up actually suing the company for discrimination
based on how they were treating, uh, you know, people of color.
So after that day with the officers in Charlotte,
the one thing I do remember dad saying was that it wasn't right did someone was
gonna fight. Right.
And that is how he ends up walking into what he's office on crutches.
In 1985 he tells what he, I want to sue the Charlotte police department.
So we went ahead and just filed our lawsuit in federal court.
Woody takes it to trial. And basically his argument is that the police,
they had used excessive force that was totally unnecessary under the
circumstances.
Like they roughed up a diabetic who is telling them that he was a diabetic and
eventually the judge presiding over the case ruled that no,
these officers did not use excessive force.
And if you are going to claim that they did,
we had to show that the police officers had acted maliciously for the purpose of
causing harm. Huh. So they,
they had to prove that the officer's actually meant to hurt him. Yeah.
That woody and into thorn had to prove that the officers had it out for thorn
and we simply couldn't do that. Yeah.
It seems like a really hard thing to prove.
It's an almost impossible standard to meet.
And I think it's important to zoom in on this for a second because this is
really kind of like the crux of the story. Um,
if the question is what should the standard be for holding a cop accountable for
the use of forests, then in the mid eighties, um,
malicious intent with sort of the prevailing standard,
if you're going to claim that a police officer used excessive force against you,
then the standard was that you had to prove that the officer did so with malice
in their heart. Why was that the standard?
This is kind of hard to explain. I don't have the 14th amendment in front of me,
but it essentially says all you really need to know is that it was connected to
the 14th amendment to a particular clause in the 14th amendment.
And this is why woody and de Thoren lost that case. Okay. All right.
So loses it federal court lose it.
Federal makes its way up to the Fourth Circuit Court of appeals that went
nowhere. The court of Appeals ruled against us. Same thing. Same thing.
But then not long after that ruling what he gets a phone call radio.
Can you hear me from this guy? Yep. Jerry beaver,
unknown civil rights lawyer in the area in Fayetteville, North Carolina.
Gerald was older and wiser than me. That's your wording, not mine. Jerry. Hey.
Caught wind of the circuit decision and was just like, oh no, no, no, no, no,
no, no.
You should not have to require that the police officer had it in for you and
just wanting to beat the crap out. That'd be just cause it made him feel better.
So I called woody and said,
are you guys planning on taking this case to the Supreme Court?
And when he was like, no, my client can't really afford that. And I said,
tell him he doesn't have to worry about that.
We will be glad to take it on pro bono.
And see if we can get this ruling over return. When he heard that what he said,
sure, let's go.
So Jane would he get together and they started looking around like what's out
there?
What cases can we draw in to argue that there should be a different standard and
it's just so happened this is the mid eighties and there was this well of police
use of force cases kind of bubbling up in the courts and you had lawyers trying
out all these different ideas.
Now most of the courts were using the 14th amendment malicious intent standard
that Jared would even like.
Then there was also in the number of cases the eighth amendment.
What's the eighth one? Unusual punishment. He justice prior.
The eighth is cruel and unusual punishment problem there,
which doesn't totally explain it zone what is cruel? What is unusual?
Like take the word cruel.
Cruel seems to imply that intent that you're trying to hurt somebody,
which means if you're going to prove anything,
you still have to call inside somebody's head. Right? But
there was this other amendment that some of the courts were using that what do
you and Jerry looked to as their sort of like redeemer? The fourth amendment,
the fourth amendment, the fourth amendment which is,
which is the government cannot subjects.
Edison's to Andre's most search and seizure.
I have it on my legal pad.
The fourth amendment is the right of the people to be secure in their persons
houses,
papers and effects against unreasonable searches and seizures shall not be
violated and is seizure just another a word for force,
like I have the right not to be like beaten or shot by my government. Yeah.
Yeah. It's not just that, but yes. It also includes that and did Jane,
what do what they like so much about the fourth amendment is that in there is
this one important word, unreasonable, reasonable,
reasonable concept of reasonableness.
What is reasonable and what is not reasonable in law?
Reasonable is is supposed to be objective.
You look at the case from the facts of the case. You look at the WHO, what,
where, when, not the Y. Correct. Then you ask,
was this person's behavior reasonable or not?
They have to act with objective reasonableness. Wait a second.
I mean reasonableness as a slippery thing. What you find reasonable,
what I find reasonable could very well be different,
could be completely different. Yes and no. It can feel slippery,
but legally the whole concept of reasonableness had hundreds of years of
precedent. I mean, I,
I find this very fascinating and I don't know if you want me to give you like a
little bit of a backstory. Well,
do you want to give me a little bit of, I think it's Kinda, it's,
it's interesting how it came to be and how popular it is. Yeah.
You can take me out. Take me on the ride. Okay. All right. So, uh,
we go back to like the 1830s that Andrew Jackson area. Now he's actually,
we're over in Europe. Uh, we're in Belgium. Uh,
this is going to be like a little windy, but I think it kind of makes sense.
So in the 1836 guy,
adult Kettler adult kettle a is a mathematician, he's an astronomer.
If you want to picture something, he had hollow cheeks. He's big sideburns.
Looked a little bit like, um, David straitharn the,
the guy from the Edward Moreau movie,
the Jason Bourne movies, if you've, if that helps you at all. Yeah, yeah,
totally. It's great. Anyhow, uh, he was a super smart guy and an 1830s,
the Belgian government wanted to set up an observatory,
but astronomers have this issue, um,
that they had trouble pinpointing the location of stars because their telescopes
were just so bad.
But Kennedy was one of these astronomers who knew you could use, uh,
statistics to figure these things out.
You could take an average of all the different measurements and average of the
meteorological data and that can help you pinpoint where stars were actually
going to be in the sky so that they can make predictions.
And it's interesting to know that, yeah,
this statistical average thing was like revolutionizing astronomy.
And so what happened is kettle a became fascinated by this idea of averages.
And what he did is he, he kind of took that idea,
like took it down from the heavens, from the sky,
and started applying it to humans.
So we began combing through data and medical journals,
trying to determine the average height of a person, the average weight, um,
the circumference of somebody's chest.
Was he trying to like come up with these sort of Prodo man kind of thing? Yeah,
totally. And it would have a huge impact on public health,
but he ends up actually going beyond this and it's beyond just like physical
traits.
And he starts to like push into man's morality and he's looking at crime rates,
suicide rates, marriage rates. And in the 1830s,
he starts laying out this concept what is, uh, in French, uh,
loam Moines, which translates into the average man,
the average man. So, so this is like big data, 1830 style. Yeah.
And this idea of low Moynihan, the average man, it became, uh,
very useful in law, English law. Really. How exactly,
let me explain. In Victorian England,
there is much to do about people who wanted to sue for damages or left
advantages. There was a need for constant averages,
a way to take measure in stock to see if a person had straight from the flock.
This surely seem like the best way to determine if the accused had to pay at
your wet. Are you doing that? Stands alone. Alright,
on the two English judges they decreed, here's how we will fill this need.
Put a man on the stand,
have him raise his right hand.
Let's say you stack some hay in a terribly negligent way.
Much more like a funeral pyre caught his neighbor's home totally on fire.
But he says the days are hot and long that he did nothing wrong. So Jerry,
I ask of you, what is it that we shall do? How about think of ordinary folk,
your average typical reasonable bloke.
And then [inaudible] take a look at the accused at hand and ask yourself this
one question. Did he behave like your ordinary,
average, reasonable man?
Wow,
I didn't even know you had that in you. Guilty. [inaudible] okay. Are.
So you're saying that judges and juries began to use these averages as a way to
sort of like figure out like if you're suing somebody else that,
that somebody else, did they act out of the ordinary where they unreasonable?
Yeah. And it was just a few years after and this whole average man thing,
that English law started developing this idea,
this standard known initially as the reasonable man standard, um,
eventually switches to person a to be a little bit more gender inclusive. Uh,
this reasonable person.
It's one of the longest established fictional characters that exists in what is
known as like the legal village where you have these other little characters.
Like it starts with the reasonable person and then you start,
you get like a slew of these other,
these other characters that come out of that, which is a, I have a little list.
There's the ordinary prudent man of business,
the officious bystander. There is the fair minded and informed observer.
There's the reasonable juror, there's the reasonable parent,
there's the reasonable landlord,
there's a reasonable neurosurgeon or reasonable civil engineer.
There's also a reasonable hairdresser. Really, it's sort of like,
it's like in any sort of, uh, uh, trade or craft, um,
where there's business being done or you have the ability within your craft to
harm somebody legally.
It became very useful to have an average archetypal person doing that craft so
that the jury or the judge, um,
would have something to use as a measurement when rendering judgment.
That's interesting. So like in the hairdresser example,
whatever it was that led to that phrase probably was a kettle and survey in at
least an imagined one of hairdresser behavior. Yeah. Like,
like maybe you went in to get a haircut and you walked out and half year's gone,
right. And you're just like, where'd half my year ago?
And then it's just you go to court and you're like,
any reasonable hairdresser would not have made that cut. Right.
That's so interesting.
So it starts with this astronomer and ends up with this village of
reasonableness.
Chime in with the funny thing about the village something please.
This is pretty straight Kelly prime. So like in English law, um, like Matt said,
there's like this village of people,
but in England at the time they had this idea that the,
it wasn't like a village, it was people on a bus.
It was called the man on the Clapham Omnibus, which is a roughly,
I looked up at London bus route 88 ways.
So this is like a bus full of racist people. All those people, are they going,
I don't know, they just ride all day though. All those
people just waiting for the case to come up and be like, oh,
that's your hairdresser. Um,
and then like that concept moved and like Australia was like, okay,
we should use that.
And so one part called that the man on the Bondi Tram and another part called
the man on the Burke street tram and then Hong Kong got it.
And they said it's the man on the uh, shank shonky one tram.
So the bus is just a convenient vessel to hold all these reasonable people. So,
um,
England said all these people are on a bus because you didn't want someone is
like, like so lowly that they are like, they're not riding the bus.
They're like hold up in a cave somewhere or someone that is like high up on
their castle. It's like the common man. Yeah, exactly. So it said, um,
it was described as reasonably educated, intelligent but nondescript.
And I think like what, what woody and Jerry to bring in all the way back,
we're essentially trying to do is to say we need to use the fourth amendment and
this idea of unreasonable search and seizure to create a reasonable officer.
Oh,
so we need to add an reasonable officer to the village or the bus.
So rarely the cases submitted in 1989 almost five years after everything
happened to, to Thorn Graham that one day in Charlotte,
we'll hear argument next to number 87 65 71 his case went before the Supreme
Court. So you form Graham versus Ms. Honor.
Now Thorn wasn't there for the arguments.
What he was there as a spectator to watch. Jerry was actually arguing the case.
Did you have butterflies? Of course you may proceed whenever you're ready.
Just to chief justice,
may I please the court and pretty quickly these arguments you don't know and so
getting really unreasonable,
I didn't know what the subjective intent of the officer's are turned into like
this word,
some objective standard where you got Jerry the lawyer for the officer's
subjective, the justices objective, subjective dichotomy,
but just getting super meta about what constitutes objectivity objectively
unreasonable at subjectivity. Subjective factor have analysis,
tests and standards, severe objective tests. The objective analysis, bad intent,
no intent. Subjective intent. I think we're playing with words there until,
well, one justice Thurgood Marshall,
the Loan African-American on the court comes in and just asked
what reason was there for him come from the diabetic in a coma?
Well, at the time the officers didn't know that he was a a diabetic in a coma.
The a
what was he doing that was so violent that he had to be a handcuff?
Yeah, to, to go back. One step. Even before that,
officer Connor saw petitioner acting a very suspicious and unusual manner.
Peaceful. Well, it wasn't clear. He saw him hurry into a convenience store.
Excuse me. What did he do that was violent?
Mr Barry's testimony? Yes.
Petitioners on witness said that a petitioner was throwing his hands around that
Barry had asked for officer condoms.
The one I'm talking about before they put handcuffs on him.
What was he doing before they tried to put, so
he was acting in a very bizarre manner. He ran out of the car,
circled around twice, and then sat down the district court.
Was that threatening anybody? Did he strike any man? Well,
the officers didn't have [inaudible] until he did he strike anybody.
I don't believe the record indicates that he started either threatened the
strike anybody.
He was acting Indian, indirectly indictable and potentially dangerous man.
In your answer, did he threatened to strike in the body?
He did not overtly threatened to strike anyone.
Did he have a weapon of any kind? Are the record doesn't indicate,
I don't believe he directed. Didn't show he had a weapon to Vegas.
That's correct. But the record, why was he handcuffed?
The record shows that he was properly stomped as a suspect for a criminal
investigation, that he was acting suspiciously,
that he was acting in a bizarre manner and did even after he was handcuffed and
the officers wanted to put him in a car,
the undisputed record shows that he was vigorously fighting and kicking.
Well, she said, look,
diabetic objective being arrested rather than given treatment.
He wasn't arrested, he was never arrested. Was He handcuffed?
He was handcuffed because the officers were concerned that he was a criminal
suspect. He was acting in a very unusual and erratic way.
He was throwing his hands around and do the district court stated from the
record that he was handcuffed in part to protect himself as well as the officers
and all the protections that's there. The district court summarize the record,
uh, as indicating that that's correct.
Now they are definitely
now you different collusion. Um,
when Justice Marshall said that suddenly I heard a judge
who understood our point of view,
somebody gets it and all of a sudden I felt like I was not an idiot.
After all.
[inaudible]
the court eventually puts out their opinion.
It's written by the chief justice William Rehnquist. And in that opinion,
Rehnquist says, uh, skipping down here a little bit, um,
claims that law enforcement officials have used excessive force in the course of
an arrest,
investigatory stop or other quote unquote seizure of a free citizen are most
properly characterized as invoking the protections of the fourth amendment,
which guarantees citizens the right to be secure in their persons against
unreasonable seizures and must be judged by reference to the fourth amendments
reasonableness standard. So they get their reasonable officer standard,
they get it and they get it unanimously. But nothing, nothing opinion. Whoa.
It was a breakthrough.
I don't think it'd be a stretch to say that at the time too.
A lot of people who were concerned about police brutality, police use force,
it felt like this was the beginning of a new
era that favor plaintiffs and claimants.
Because now if you were a victim of police violence and you wanted some justice,
you had this new universal standard and objective standard where you no longer
had to show that the officers acted maliciously or sadistically.
You don't have to get inside the officer's head.
You don't have to prove they had bad intent.
You just look at the case from the facts of the case and you say what a
reasonable officer do the same thing or not.
And you could establish like what a reasonable officer is,
what they would do by calling experts,
looking at data about age and rank and experience all sorts of things.
But the thought was that this,
the objectives
for the first time in hundreds of years,
maybe they would have an objective standard that was a breakthrough.
So w after winning did the case get kicked back down to the circuit,
like what happens to the thorn?
Um, after we won in the Supreme Court,
the case went back to the trial court level for another trial.
That was the effect of it. And so Mr. Graham had another day in court,
another trial. We picked another jury.
The facts were presented a better insulin reaction. Bottle of orange shoes,
pulled him over. Unconscious handcuffed, physical altercation, broken foot,
lacerations risks, Bruce forehead, squad, car, front yard.
Essentially he was the guy who did nothing wrong and was beaten up.
The case was given to the jury
as Jerry was told. Okay. Knowing what you now know,
take the standard as reasonable as standard and ask yourself is what happened to
disarm Graham reasonable.
The jury deliberated,
came back out and laid aside in favor of the police officers. Mr. Graham lost
[inaudible].
Now whether you think this is reasonable or not,
the jury really focused in on the police officer's perspective and from the
officer's perspective,
all they saw was a black man running in and out of convenience store.
They thought he might be stealing something.
They had no idea who was a diabetic. And when the police picked him up,
he was a little bit out of control. Exactly weird.
He's walking around the car creating trouble. Not because he's a diabetic,
but he's a drug. Might be dangerous.
A reasonable officer would subdue that person.
[inaudible]
excuse me. I'm so sorry. Oh, I'm at the door though.
Here there goes the dogs or the dogs.
So when I talked it throw in Graham Jr he was actually moving from his home in
St Louis. That Brian,
I'm just going to open the garage up for this guy back to where you still had a
lot of family in Charlotte. Okay. I'm back, hopefully. All right, cool. Okay,
now, um, I, I was just wondering, did your dad talk about the,
about what happened that day or did he talk about the court case at all? No,
he didn't. It wasn't something that he talked about to thorn.
Jeannie says that his dad was just kind of trying to get on with his life. He,
he started making furniture in his spare time, going to church a lot,
but he had his, he had his troubles. He had, uh, he ended up having a,
a substance
abuse issues. So, uh,
and which fortunately he was able to overcome that.
And that was after the Supreme Court case? After the, that's correct.
That's correct.
Hmm.
And so, I mean, I don't know if his,
his way of trying to deal with that was to substance abuse. I don't know.
You know, uh, you know,
when you are dehumanized like that, when,
when another individual, whether they, it's, you know,
it's, it's, it's Kinda hard to explain that. But when,
when someone who has authority
just, it's, it's, it's like, it's, they,
it's like they take something away from you.
When someone does something like that to you,
it strikes at your core. It strikes at your very being.
And I think you lose a part of yourself that you can't get back.
It's on Graham Sr died in the year 2000. He was 54 years old,
but after his death, his name lived on in this case,
in this very weird way.
So 2014 rear is growing outrage tonight after an unarmed African American
teenager was shot and killed by police in the St Louis suburb of Ferguson,
Missouri. Not far from where does Lauren Jeannie lives?
A white officer Garren Wilson shot and killed a black teenager, Michael Brown,
a reporter from CNN contacted me. And uh,
he talked about how they were going to use my dad's case during that trial as a
defense for the officer, the CNN report informing them. Do you know about this?
No, I had no idea.
The grand jury deliberated over two days making their final decision.
One of the questions posted, the jury was,
did officer Darren Wilson Act reasonably when he shot Michael Brown?
They determined that no probable cause exists to file any charge against officer
Wilson and return to no true bill on each of the five indictments.
And the jury was basically like, yeah, that was reasonable.
That's fine. I think that the fucking
killed her baby man. Where did they
get nobody back?
[inaudible]
later that same year,
the 12 year old boy was shot and killed by two officers while holding a pellet
gun to me race,
we are instructed to ask what a reasonable police officer would do in this
particular situation.
The jury found that the officer who shot and killed the 12 year old boy,
Tamir Rice acted reasonably and then
right, right, right. That Eric Gardner of grand jury in New York
City has refused to indict yet another white police officer said to have killed
an unarmed black man. His death. What's reasonable? John Crawford,
22 year old black man killed last month,
reasonable carrying around the BB gun for a judge declared in this trial today,
Samuel Dubose and the case of a white police officer who killed an unarmed black
man, reasonable with sterling on his back. Alton Sterling,
one officer pulls his gun,
reasonable sterling laid dying on the street. Terence Crutcher,
unarmed black man, reasonable shot and killed by police in Oklahoma.
Charlotte police, Keith Lamont, Scott GMR, Clark,
Liz [inaudible] jail, my son,
Philando Castiel. Reasonable.
Oh, are you kidding me right now, we're not evolving as a sibling loss.
Say you work the Bobby,
we're going back down to 1969 damn
[inaudible]
and in almost every one of those cases, Graham versus Connor,
the Supreme Court decision that many people felt was supposed to establish a new
universal standard that would deliver justice for victims of police violence.
And almost every one of those cases it ended up doing the exact opposite.
It prevented the victims from getting relief and instead protected the cops.
One person, my colleague who covers cops describes it as like cops.
Cops see it as like their first amendment.
[inaudible]
after the break we'll ask how did that happen?
and we'll watch it happen
[inaudible]
more. Perfect. We'll continue in a moment.
Radio lab. We'll continue in a moment.
This is Christopher calling from south Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org hey podcast listeners.
There's a new podcast coming from wny se studios and it's for kids.
Wow. Can you hear my voice or the headphones?
This podcast has fleas,
tells the story of a dog and a cat who live in the same house but have competing
podcasts. Cat Lovett is laugh on the little box coming at you. What a show.
So I am just [inaudible] this podcast has,
please subscribe where ever you get your podcasts.
This is more perfect. I'm Jad Abumrad.
We're featuring more perfect on Radiolab today. Uh,
and let me just say a few words for context.
Police officers have dangerous jobs. I think we can all agree.
And on occasion they do have to use force.
And we should say that the majority of the people who are killed by police every
year are white. But if you look at the number of black people who are killed,
and you balance that against the fact that black people only make up about 12%
of the overall population,
what you end up with is that an unarmed black man is roughly about seven times
more likely to be killed by police in an unarmed white man.
That's according to one study.
Now these numbers are very disputed and argued about,
but what is clear is most police officers who use deadly force are never
charged. And the even smaller percentage serve jail time. So Matt, yes,
Matt Kielty. Let me just ask you,
like all the cases we heard about before the break,
that litany of cases from the past few years in every single one of those,
the jury was asked, did this officer behave like a reasonable officer should?
And in every single one the jury said yes. Yeah, yeah. Why?
Well that's, it's because, uh, the reasonable officer standard, like from,
from the moment that it was created, uh, it was actually Kinda,
it was constrained in a few very important ways.
Yeah. And actually like, um, I have here the,
the jury instructions from the ninth circuit and this is what jury members are,
are told to think about when they have to assess this kind of use of force case.
Yeah. Yeah. And so the jury jurors are actually told this is your job exactly.
Prime Time Kelly prime. Yeah. So it says under the fourth amendment,
a police officer may use only such force as objectively reasonable. Uh,
you must judge the reasonableness of a particular use of force from the
perspective of a reasonable officer on the scene and not with 20,
20 vision of hindsight.
Those, those are, um, a couple of really crucial phrases,
which is perspective of, uh,
an officer on the scene.
So you have to look at it through the eyes of the officer on the scene and then
you can't look at it through the 2020 vision of hindsight.
So you have to put yourself in the shoes of an officer in the moment and look at
the world through their eyes.
And that's how you have to understand these things. And where did that,
where did, where did that idea come from? So that comes from Graham.
Like that comes from, uh, the chief justice, uh, William Rehnquist's, uh,
opinion, which I have right here.
The reasonableness of a particular use of forests must be judged from the
perspective of a reasonable officer on the scene rather than with the 2020
vision of hindsight. And it's calculus must embody an allowance for the fact.
And this is extremely important that police officers are often forced to make
split second decisions about the amount of force necessary in a particular
situation. And so as you can see, this,
this idea of reasonableness is circumscribed very tightly by time.
It's not asking like what a reasonable officer would do here in,
in general during a moment where, um, where they have to use force.
Instead.
What it's asking is what would reasonable officer do in this split second,
in this little tiniest sliver of time where, where the force actually occurred.
And in fact, that moment legally has come to be known, um,
as a super seeding event. Meaning what, what does that mean? Um,
meaning this is, I find this kind of crazy, uh, meaning that, that,
that moment, that superseding event,
essentially it breaks the chain of causation.
So if, if you think of time as just this like continuous flow, this is like no,
you break that,
you stop that and you take this one little moment and you pluck it out and
you're like, this moment, this is the one moment that you look at,
that's all that they can think about the jurors, right?
And it turns out if you ask a jury the question about use of force that way,
about this one little moment, the Graham standard that many people thought, um,
and hoped would, would help victims of police violence does the exact opposite.
One person, my,
my colleague who covers cops describes that as like cops cops see it as like
their first amendment. They just think of it like as a shield. Yeah. Okay.
So this is NPR reporter Kelly McEvers, um,
host of embedded podcast and all things considered.
So Kelly's actually a,
she's covered police shootings for the past like year for NPR.
And we've sorta been comparing notes with her as we've been producing our story.
And a little while back she sent us an email basically saying that she had this
opportunity to go and see something that most people don't get to see,
to sort of see how cops are actually trained to understand Graham.
And so she has this do you want in? And we were like, yeah,
let's go. Okay. So I went to Cleveland on,
Oh,
you hung over cop calls get me shit started for this two day training course
called street survival. It was in a hotel ballroom,
one of those hotel ballrooms where you have like a big conference and how many
people do you remember? Um, there was somewhere just under 200. Um, cops
[inaudible]
lots of really jacked dudes with tats. Mostly white.
There were some sergeants and lieutenants, rookies right out of the academy,
some mid career guys from all over Ohio,
Pennsylvania and they were not super happy about me being there.
Did you get like angry stares?
I mean in the beginning there's just like a lot of Sida
[inaudible]
nice. Good Morning Cleveland. How's everybody doing? All right, good.
How many of you have been to a caliber press seminar before? Please show hands.
Let's do it this way. There's never been here before. Never been uncovered.
Press class. Oh Wow. Good, good deal.
Kelly said the whole thing is put on by this company called caliber press.
It's a company that's actually been around for a really long time and they teach
classes, classes that are aimed at police departments.
They all from all across country and this particular
one we're gonna talk a lot about stress, survival instincts.
The general idea is how to survive and like make it to retirement.
I mentioned heart attacks, emotional health, suicide,
you know how to basically do this job and really about 24 seven survive and
live,
living and lasting a 25 30 year career.
They talk a lot about self care. What do you need about sleep and exercise?
I remember my wife and I talked about this if,
but if I start getting crabby or is there something else there?
Making sure that your spouse and your family like understand the stresses of
your job and they talk about going to therapy. I mean it's like wow,
there's times when it's this really touchy feely kind of thing.
I just started getting overwhelmed.
I didn't know what was happening with [inaudible].
There was, even though when she says, when an officer got up,
talked about contemplating suicide,
why? Why aren't you telling me I need you to get, Oh,
I started secluding was, I just started alienating myself.
It was awkward hating everybody. Everyone was like crying.
So I mean it's a really intense couple of days.
But for our purposes,
the reason we were there or the reason we were excited for Kelly to be there is
that a big chunk of the class, let's talk about the,
is devoted to cram.
[inaudible] actually uses force that teaching these cops how to understand gram
and, and how it impacts their lives. Um, and by the way,
this is the instructor that like Graeme instructor, his name is Jim Glennon.
G M self was a cop for years and years and years.
I was in charge of use of force for 18 years.
Was the lieutenant outside of Chicago. Yeah.
I tell you, we talked about brand versus Connor and our use of force, uh,
policies on a regular basis. I mean I got up four times a year and just read.
What I would do is show a video and then let's talk about,
or Scott or based on this video,
so fired up the projector.
It is really interesting to see these videos from their perspective.
Like this one video about presto police, September,
2015 a guy named Freddie Senteno. What are your role, Bryce and 10 oh,
she's gone to a woman's house like to a woman's front door and threatened her
and says he has a gun and the cops pull up, get out of their car.
They're just like 20 feet away from Centeno.
Who's walking towards them on the sidewalk?
Hey
[inaudible]
10 shots. Seven of them hit
47 Frank Long. I translated wild 1.5659999999999998 sec.
Jim's claims it happens in 1.5659999999999998 seconds.
Mentally Disabled Madness at certain times and dies in the hospital 23 days like
and in one of these news clips that Jim shows the lawyer for Freddie Centeno,
his family is basically just like, I'm not, you know, bat shooting. That's,
that's an atrocity. Like this was an atrocity.
Nothing about this use of force should be considered reasonable because the cops
in this situation,
they rolled right up on Freddie Centeno. They didn't create any space.
They didn't give Freddy Centeno any time.
They told him get on the ground, you didn't have a chance to get on the phone.
One second before he began to fire and he gives the owners view the video shows
the officers did not give Santana with chance to respond to their demand.
So Jim plays all these reaction clips and then what happens is real quick,
he plays the original body cam video again. Hey Fred, look,
we see Freddy Centeno, they tell them to get on the ground. He doesn't.
And then Jim slows the video down and when he does you can see Centeno.
His right hand reaches into his pocket.
[inaudible]
Jim Pauses and he's like,
take a look at this right here and up on the screen.
Jim has this frozen moment where you can see that Freddy Santana's hand has
started to move over the banana.
Couple of it's just starting to come up out of his pocket.
This moment from the pocket to the out of the pocket is to, Jim was the moment.
The moment. Remember that Tim's like, this is the only moment that matters.
Like forget what happened before.
Forget that the officers rolled right up on centennial.
Forget that they weren't giving a much time or space.
It's this moment right here when Senteno starts pulling his hand out of his
pocket. This is the moment where you asked the question,
what would a reasonable officer do right now?
This man appears to be pulling out an object from his pocket.
I can't tell what it is, and you probably can't eat it outside information.
Turns out he had a a nozzle from a garden hose.
What was the call? Malaga. However you see this,
whether he started moving up or down, he doesn't go to the ground.
He goes into his pocket and pull something out. They think it's a gun.
Any reasonable person would think it's a gun.
[inaudible]
does this work under Graham? Yeah.
It's sad. Yeah, but yes. Yes, underground.
It's fine. All right. Wait
for him.
He's just like over and over and overstress is what would a reasonable police
officer do?
What moment do you use force in that moment? What did you know?
How would you put it on what you should, what did you know what was going on?
Would it sets up there.
He talks about Rehnquist and the decision. He's like, what rank was said is,
Oh, I was supposed to be made for the fact we stopped.
We started off with force may split second judgments in circumstances that are
tense, uncertain, rapidly. Bobby, Bobby,
amount of force is necessary in a particular situation.
This is fast. It's dynamic. It's nothing like television.
There's no five cameras on it, there's no change in the music.
There's no upswell in the music. It's fast.
And the court recognizes that this is an Albuquerque case.
Jim Plays another example, a this one of the guy, white guy,
police officer shot because they thought he had a gun.
[inaudible] got get a knife, but the cops have gotten called in.
He had a gun and in the split second he raised his arm like he was raising a gun
up. And so the cop shot him.
Does this work under Graham? Yeah.
Another one I talked to this officer [inaudible] gets a call to be a domestic,
showed another video of the police shooting an unarmed white man in the head.
And again,
he walked through it beat by beat with grant you here to put yourself in that
officers position. Right. Said you got to look at just the superseding moment,
forget everything else. And what you realize if you do that,
if you forced the say a jury to look at just that one moment for getting
everything else, just look at this one slice through the eyes of an officer.
Then the whole concept of what is reasonable
shifts.
And the only real question you can ask when the moment is so confined is did the
officer feel threatened?
Like was the fear that that officer had a reasonable fear in that moment
and that is a very different standard than what would he in Jerry into Thorn
Graham had intended? Um, yeah,
so Kelly actually told us a story that she reported for her podcast embedded
that actually gets it some of this stuff in this particular case.
Who was John and Farrell and what happened to them? Pharell um,
it was a football player. He's from Florida. Is he big dude? Yes. Okay.
He looks like a football player.
So this was September of 2013 John Farrell is living in Charlotte,
North Carolina. He's a black man, 24 years old and one night,
it was a Friday night, he goes out with some friends cause that to a bar.
He has a couple of drinks, makes his way home. You know,
we don't exactly know what happened but well Jonathan Ferrell was making his way
back home at some point. His car was, he lost control of his car,
crashed in the woods off this road in suburban Charlotte.
He didn't have his phone but he's in like this little suburban neighborhood.
So he gets out of his car, goes up to the house of,
this woman is knocking on her door. The woman inside, she's a white woman,
new mom. She comes to the door thinking it's her husband who works nights.
So she just comes to the door and she's like about to let him in and then she's
like, Whoa, wait a second. Who is this person? Panty. She opens the doors.
Each one of them fail and quickly closes it.
No one. Hello cause she calls nine one one.
I know I need help on their way to die hill and my front door.
Is it ever hand your front door? Yeah, you can do it now
the woman tells the dispatcher and she doesn't know who the guy is.
Usually the black now. Okay.
Car alarm systems going off.
All right. Okay. I'm my hair.
You can hear Jonathan Ferrell screaming. Turn off the alarm.
Turn off the alarm in the background and you can hear him in the nine one one
tape. You can like hear him banging on the door.
Yeah, I know who still there. Yeah.
Do you have your baby with you know, I don't know what to do.
Okay, I'm right here. You're on our way. Okay.
Now we don't know why Jonathan Ferrell was banging on the door,
but very possible.
Very likely it was just because he wrecked his car and needed some help. Right.
So three officers get called to the scene thinking that they are going to the
scene of a breaking and entering.
There's a dash cam video from the squad car baloney officers.
They've gotten a description.
It's an African American man with green shirt and light pants.
So this officer is driving down this road, driving, driving,
driving until finally you see an African American man in the green shirt and
light pants walking on the side of the road. He's
walking towards the squad cars.
You see the red light of a teaser on his [inaudible]
chest and then fail just like takes off.
One of the officers is yelling at him to get on the ground.
The fuel keeps running, runs off camera, can't see what happens next. But then,
yeah,
[inaudible]
one of the officer's fires, 12 shots, 10 of them straight, John Farrell,
he falls to the ground. Okay,
well dot. Black dot slide
and he dies.
The facts of this case are that here's a guy who was unarmed,
who did nothing wrong, and then he was killed like plain and simple. If you,
if you asked was that reasonable on some basic level, no,
it was not reasonable. This man should not have died. But in the trial,
this case did go to a trial, a jury trial. The jury was instructed,
forget everything. But that moment of force, like no 2020 hindsight,
look at just the super moment and then ask the question again.
Was it reasonable for the officer to pull the trigger? I. E.
Was it reasonable for that officer to be afraid?
And the officer who shot and killed Jonathan Ferrell who was facing charges,
his name was Randall Kerrick. He was being tried for voluntary manslaughter.
The suspect began aggressively coming towards me.
And during the course of this trial,
officer Kerrick took the stand and could you tell the jury about what pace he
was coming at you? At first it was a pretty rapid pace,
more more of a fast walk.
I gave loud verbal commands for him to stop and get on the ground.
How loud were your verbal commands?
Very loud tells you,
show the jury how loud you were yelling to the suspect and what you were yelling
to the suspect.
[inaudible]
so he says he was running at him and this is a huge question.
Was he running at him or was he running away from it?
I tried to run past him by him. Yeah.
Like if you sort of diagram the whole thing out,
the way the cop cars were parked, the way Kerrick was standing,
it is possible that Jonathan Ferrell was trying to sort of run between the mall.
That's what the prosecution was saying. The defense was like, no, no, no, no.
He was running at the cops.
Did the suspect say anything to you? No Sir.
Where did you interpret his body language to mean he was going to attack me.
He was gonna assault me. Who's going to take my gun from me?
Did you have time to holster your weapon? No, sir.
And here I was suspect matched the description and he just ran through a taser,
which at the time I felt was had, had worked.
I felt the Taser had struck and made contact and I had absolutely no idea if he
had a weapon on him or not. And was he ever, was the suspect ever still?
No Sir. Did he continue to advance on you?
Yes sir. I met her. What I did, he wouldn't stop.
I wasn't sure how many rounds I had fired. None of them affected him in any way,
any way. I didn't think my gun was working.
I thought I was gonna die because nothing I would do would stop him.
What was the reason that you continue to fire your weapon?
Because he wouldn't stop. He kept trying to get to my gun.
To boil it down, the question was,
was it reasonable for officer Carrick to feel afraid?
And after 11 days of testimony, the question was put to the jury,
there were six opinions. One way there were six another.
When they first go into the jury room, it was six to six on one side,
a white guy named Bruce Raffey.
We were sitting in that courtroom and we were sitting in that,
that jury deliberation room was no bigger than this living room. Okay.
And it's hot. We're arguing where it's, it's,
it's going nowhere. And so the more it went on,
this went on for days and he's sort of the leading the charge on that.
We have to acquit Kerrick side.
He felt that officer Kerrick had every right to be afraid.
And he told Kelly that Jonathan Ferrell, the guy who Karen shot.
So what Bruce Raffy saying to me like, you know, he was a young man, distraught,
disheveled, confused, angry, if you will.
He made a very aggressive move towards these police officers after disobeying
commands,
you have many choices in this video and it was clear from the very first time I
viewed it, stop, sit down, put your hands up,
do any of those things other than what you chose to do,
which was to charge the officer character. And so there,
there's no other way around. What I saw and it kept coming back to that,
and this is exactly how the defense painted it, right?
This case is not about race. This case is about choices.
And that stuck in Bruce Rafferty's mind so that when he was asked was it
reasonable for character, shoot him. It's like,
Well Yeah Cause Jonathan Ferrell made all these bad choices.
This is an old trick from,
from from defense attorneys is another one that chairs that Kelly spoke to named
Moses Wilson, an African American man.
He wasn't supposed to be here.
He might've had a few drinks where he was.
The police responded to what he caused.
This was early in the morning. This was bar from where he lived.
This was this,
this was that which caused me at the end to write on the board just what did he
do to deserve to be shot.
So many times I notice in the jury room I wrote this on the board.
What did he do
well, so what happens with the jury?
It's blitz. Eventually Italians eat to acquit for to convict eight jurors.
Most of them wait side with acquitting carer and four jurors,
most of them people of Color side with convicting Kerrick
breaking news. In the trial of officer Randall Kerrick,
the judge has just declared a mistrial this after
2015 the city of Charlotte settled the lawsuit with John Farrell's family for
2.2 $5 million. Later that same year,
officer Kerrick resigned from the Charlotte Police Department.
The city paid out $179,989 and 59 cents the money was for back pay,
Kerrick, social security and retirement.
And an attorney that represented him in a separate civil suit. Yeah.
There's something interesting about listening to Moses talk,
just what did he do to deserve to be shot so many times because it feels like
this, um, fourth amendment reasonableness standard,
this reasonable officer standard. Like what, from what I understand is,
is that it was an attempt to really kind of
look at these situations, these shootings,
these uses of force cases through this sort of objective lens where you're just
looking at all the facts on the ground. Um,
and yet the cases don't seem to be tied to it. Like any sort of objectivity.
Yeah. There's something about hearing Moses where you're like, oh,
that's actually like, that feels like a pure sort of objectivity.
Like what, what did, what had this guy done? He hadn't actually done anything.
He ran it. Somebody maybe, but that was [inaudible].
Yeah. And like if this is the thing,
like if you're white,
are you more likely to say yes,
that was reasonable because he's white and he was afraid of a black man, right.
Like that is the question.
I don't know, given the history of our country, I'd say in many cases,
that's not even a question.
Right.
But I guess the question I'm actually left with is
if this is where the reasonableness standard has lettuce,
is there another standard? I think that's right. This is woody canet again,
he represented to Thorne Graham in that original case. Um,
when you see it applied,
you wonder whether or not this is the best dander or there might be something
better. I just don't have an answer to that. I, I would,
I would suggest a whole more radical standard that this is an Ellie Ms Dahl,
more perfect legal editor. Uh, we ended up talking with him about this, uh,
shortly after the Philando Casteel Vardy came out. So he was, uh,
well that was a tough pill for him and many people to swallow.
I would suggest that they have to be, the cops have to be right. In fact,
which is something we usually do not apply to the law. What does that mean?
Like from a, in a, in the scenario of a police person who's, does that mean?
Like I need to be right that you don't have a toy gun.
Is that that's what you mean? Yeah.
So if you shoot me because you think have a gun. I had
best have a gun and if I don't have a gun your ass is going to jail cause you
were wrong. I don't care if you really thought so.
I don't care if I was telling you I had a gun. If I,
if you are not right in fact then you have to go to jail.
I think that is,
that would be a standard that would allow us to prosecute these police officers
but then a police person is gonna just gonna argue that like you don't
understand the pressures that are under,
it's a split second decision Monday morning quarterbacking.
If you do what you just said,
we're not going to be able to do our jobs and I would say pupil, he's officer,
I'm sick of you. I would say screw you. You have had your chance,
you've had your chance to police my community without murdering us and you have
failed for 300 years. Enough.
That's what I would say to that more people might get hurt if I wasn't,
I'm willing to risk that. I'm willing to try it that way then. Gotcha.
I'd rather,
I'd rather 10 illegal shoplifting people go free than one illegal shoplifting
person get shot in the street like an animal. Gotcha.
If you want to talk about changing the standards,
that is a standard change that could help.
Yeah. That is, as Ellie said,
radical and probably not realistic given that most Americans,
according to polls respect the police, have confidence in the police,
perceive police to be, you know, the enforcers of the law.
But there are other ideas out there that are starting to bubble up.
And if what's constraining us, if what's keeping us stuck where we are,
are the words of gram,
then what offers us a way out could actually also be hiding in there.
What do you mean? Okay,
so you know how I'm chief justice Rehnquist when he wrote the decision in eating
nine, he put in a,
all these phrases that took the idea of a reasonable officer and constrained it.
So, uh, these were like, um,
it's constrained only to this little moment in time.
It's constrained to the perspective of the officers constrained that there's no
20, 20 hindsight, all of that stuff. Well, in the decision he also,
he slipped in this other phrase, uh,
he was actually calling back to an earlier decision and what he wrote was,
um, the question is whether the detached duty of circumstances justifies a
particular sort of seizure, but totality of circumstances,
totality of circumstances, which, you know,
it seems to be at odds with all of the other stuff. Right.
Which is all about like little slivers in moments. Yeah.
It's about all these little tiny little bits of time where it's Italian.
He seems to be suggesting that this is like this is the whole thing.
So he had both, both ideas in there at once. Yeah.
Which is why right now you see the lower courts are arguing about what this
phrase actually means.
And so half of the circuits are saying kind of like everything that we've
already talked about,
which is that all the totality of circumstances means is that you look at,
to answer the
question, was the officer's scared?
You look at everything that the officer would have known,
everything the officer would've seen perceived and then you ask, okay,
knowing all that, was it reasonable for the officer to be scared in the moment?
The other half of the circuit say no, no.
A totality of circumstances isn't just about what the officer knew,
what the officers saw and how it answers the moment to tell.
He means like totality,
like what did the officer do leading up to the moment,
did the officer try to get a search warrant?
Did the officer tried to deescalate the situation before using force?
Did the officer tried to subdue the person before you using deadly force?
Like suddenly all those things that are usually kept out of the frame maybe can
be let back in
[inaudible].
The Supreme Court so far has shown no interest in really non this in trying to
sort this out,
but they might because the argument is happening in the lower courts.
So in,
in a way we're kind of living at a time very much like 1984 when the thorn
Graham got pulled over outside of convenience store in Charlotte waiting to see
whether it matters that the thorn Graham wasn't trying to steal anything,
that he was just a diabetic trying to get some orange juice.
[inaudible]
did what happened to your dad affect how you thought of police?
How you thought of police at being, being a black man?
Well, you know, believe it or not, uh, it didn't.
Uh hmm. Why is that? I like to base my
opinions based on my own experiences.
My Dad, I, I can say this, Kelly and Matt,
I can remember my dad telling me stories of where he grew up in eastern North
Carolina owned a tobacco farm in that small town.
I can remember him telling me a story of a black man who had been accused of,
uh, being inappropriate with a white woman.
And how the whites got him in broad daylight and castrate a human broad day
light. And, and,
and I say that in saying that although he experienced all that stuff growing up
and the racism that he experienced growing up,
he didn't teach that to us. He didn't teach that to us.
He taught us to love people for people.
So even now myself,
I base my experience of a person.
I base my experience of the police based on my dealings with the police.
And, and not that I won't,
but I have yet to encounter a police officer who's been mean to me,
who's been rude to me, who's mistreated me.
And that's the God's honest truth without button and being completely,
when I see on the news, like the kid in the 12 year old in,
uh, that had to BB gun, Tamir Rice. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
examples like this, that, that,
that does affect me and that does make me,
does that make you think of your own children? Have you talked to your own kids?
Of course. I've got a course. I've got a 12 year old at home.
He's got BB guns that look just like real guns and you know, but he, he,
he knows that hey, they don't leave the house. What's your,
what's your 12 year olds name? Uh, my son's name is Tanner. Tanner.
And when you,
when you talked to Tanner about the fact that like the BB gun doesn't leave the
house. I mean,
what is that conversation like with the Tamir Rice when he was shot and killed
when the news story came on? I pause it and you need to do a lot of TV now.
Say come here. What? I want you to watch this right now. Tanner is 12 years old.
He's cute, he's this, he's that. But the fact of the matter,
he is in a few, few short years,
he would be considered a black man. Unfortunately,
he's going to have a target on himself. So, hey,
those BB guns you got, see this is why you can't take these out of the house.
I don't want you to take these out of the house.
Even if you're outside in New York plane and a police should happen to come down
the road. Hey, drop it, drop it immediately.
Uh,
conduct including three. Katie's reasonable.
This story was produced and reported by Matt Kielty with a big assist from Kelly
[inaudible] behavior. [inaudible] not reasonableness requirement.
They have to know they have to deal with leading three people.
Where do you think that would be? Reasonable Execution
[inaudible] unreasonable whether objective journalism behavior alone is enough.
How would a reasonable person has felt liners that make it an unreasonable
search as opposed to val lists? Because if he goes first in usually person,
they reasonable, but the things, this is a burglary was on release.
What would a reasonable person believe?
Definitely check out the other more perfect episodes. There are many more at
radiolab.org/more perfect or search for more perfect wherever you get your
podcasts. Definitely check it out. Spread the word more.
Perfect is produced by me. Jab and Rod, Susie Lichtenburg, Jenny Lawton,
Julia Longoria, and Kelly prime.